now we have to go on to this other story
now we brought this to you just a few
days ago two days after we left Las
Vegas where we pressed and press for
answers on that worst mass shooting in
US history well we learned a little more
today very interesting after refusing to
answer our questions on Wednesday Clark
County Sheriff Joe Lombardo held a press
conference he did it today earlier today
and he said they still have no motive
for the massacre and added this about
reports of a potential accomplice to
Stephen Patek I know and believe there
was only one suspect who killed 58
people and injured hundreds more there
was only one person responsible and that
was Stephen paddock he had lost a
significant amount of his monetary
wealth in close proximity to 1 October
and they may have a driving factor
associated with it we do not anticipate
charges being brought forward against
Marylou Dan Lee as to any other people
the FBI has an ongoing case against an
individual a federal interest individual
of federal interest very very
interesting looks like a grand jury may
have already been convened to pursue
this someone else whose name we don't
know connected to this horrific crime
but he says it's not Maryland family as
to any other people
the FBI has an ongoing case against an
individual a federal interest they will
not be able to elaborate on that
statement another lovely tidbit of
information this freak paddock had
multiple photos of child pornography on
his computer oh and by the way officials
announced just this week that paddocks
body was cremated and his ashes sent to
his brother in Florida Wow
joining us now to try to piece this all
together former LAPD detective Mark
Fuhrman is in Sandpoint Idaho and he's
been following all these developments
and in Las Vegas the author of the power
of relentless and the host of war now
the way in
Roots show on USA Radio Wayne Allyn root
is here Wayne let's start with you
you've been on this from the beginning
Las Vegas is your hometown from the
beginning you've raised questions about
a possible terrorist connection to this
case that the feds kind of moved quickly
to you know discount early on what did
that very odd Lombardo press conference
today tell you he looked very
uncomfortable I think every Lombardo
press conference has been odd and he
always looks uncomfortable with the FBI
staring him down behind him and we
aren't getting the answers we deserve
that's all I've ever said I don't know
that there's a terror connection nobody
knows that but I do know that we have
not gotten the right answers the people
of Vegas who call my talkshow
all the time no one believes what we've
heard from the FBI no one believes what
we've heard from the police and by the
way it's awful strange that our
president who I love you know I'm one of
the biggest fighters on behalf of Donald
Trump but he loves to wade into
controversy in crisis and chaos and
Donald Trump has said nothing about this
which leads me to believe the government
knows much more about this than they're
willing to let on so I think that
there's so much more that we're gonna
learn in the future that we just don't
know right now we're not getting the
right answers from the people in
authority
mark Fuhrman we know in the days right
after the shooting Isis and certain Isis
websites had claimed that Stephen
paddock had converted to Islam six
months earlier now we have no evidence
that he had in one that photo the only
photo of him he's you know he's a shot
glass and if he converted to Islam he
would probably probably wouldn't be
drinking but maybe he would be but you
know could could this be there could
there would be something here or is it
irresponsible even to raise that
possibility given what we know now well
look at this Isis will take a claim of
any mass murder and in hopes that nobody
else will claim it then they get credit
for it and then they are of course
terrorists and that creates terror when
you look at this you have to look at the
evidence that's all we can deal with the
Zia
you can make theories you can dream
things up you can hope things to be but
until you have evidence you can't make
any kind of conclusion that that's what
occurred so the evidence here is we had
a sole gunman that actually supplied put
in action set up and shot these people
from the Mandalay on the 32nd floor and
that is all that they can conclude at
this but mark if there is a conspirator
some day yeah but mark you know what I
just can't keep going back to
fundamental questions my fundamental
questions are photographic evidence
videotape I know when you check into
every hotel in Wayne you can chime in on
this there you are videoed every step of
the way in Las Vegas there are cameras
everywhere everywhere why have we not
seen any of that material I agree with
you evidence that rules but in the
absence of transparency what are people
to think this is 58 Americans are dead
and we're supposed to believe a guy
who's 60 something years old was running
between two - you know pedestals to
shoot the people were people who were on
the ground were reporting that there
were two different they thought there
were two different shooters multiple
witnesses said that and that the guys
like now a sprinter running between gun
positions all of that to me again I'm a
not an earring expert mark but when the
hotel doesn't release the the check-in
photos video nothing and we gotten the
guy has no the hard drive was erased all
of that is odd to me that's just as a
regular person that's odd mark 9:1 well
Lombardo he actually stated that they
look I think 25,000 feet or 25,000 video
segments that they they actually
reviewed and you can see the the volume
of work that they've had to actually go
through in the last three months but in
all that video we have once again you do
not have a homicide investigation and a
prosecution but you have civil
civil litigation you have discovery
there the private property the MGM now
it's the evidence and the police are
probably man most probably going to be
sued along with Mandalay Bay in a
security issue and a failure to do this
and a failure to do that's because
that's what attorneys do so they're not
going to share this and pollute the jury
pool until those issues are settled
Laura and I jump in here yeah I would
say it's not 1963 okay
maybe Americans believe the JFK story in
1963 but I could tell you no one I
talked to in las vegas or anywhere in
this country because my show is national
now none of the caller's believe this
story I could tell you it makes no sense
that the police in Las Vegas did not put
this in the hands of the Homicide
Division with 35 seasoned homicide cops
who've studied murders their whole life
they put it in the hands of a small
division of five police officers who
study accidental shootings by the police
I'd love anyone including mark to
explain that you can't explain to me how
a guy the age of 60 wakes up one day and
becomes Rambo and you can't explain to
me how within days of this shooting
suddenly Jared Kushner was sent to Saudi
Arabia in a pry in a in a secret visit
and that's a fact Politico out of this
visit by hasn't trot that's a pouch the
king of Saudi Arabia within days 300
ounces I've been arrested I got security
proposed gonna be a bad way and we got a
rap because we're going to clap for the
way that HAARP